britney spears and boyfriend sam askari
have got the moves
the two enjoyed a rare public outing
attending the wedding of askari's pal
and asgari himself served as the best
man
it's fun for me asgary shared a series
of photos and videos while attending his
friend's special day with britt as his
plus one
the pop star rocked a blue mini dress
with black heels while her boyfriend
wore
a suave black suit with a yellow tie
posting the pics with his longtime love
on instagram
askari wrote about last night hashtag
vaccinated hashtag
thank you science i'm really blessed
askari also shared a video of himself
and britt
dancing together with the caption thanks
to science we get to dance again
when persian and american culture
[Music]
combines
earlier this month brit opened up about
her experience getting the covet 19
vaccine
of course it was on instagram with
ascari
okay the people on the internet said it
was really really bad it was like a
bullet going for your arm it was nothing
i felt nothing
i'm fine and i hope i continue to stay
fine
and who knows maybe a wedding for these
two
is in the future sam previously told et
that marriage was definitely something
he and brittany had talked about
is she the one do you see marriage in
the future i mean absolutely this is
something that every couple should do
that's the whole point of a relationship
we're a family
[Music]